nous avons fait
55 % marine a fait 55 % dans 87
circonscription et elle a fait plus de
50% dans 5 557 circonscription donc vous
voyez que nos perspectives
raisonnables peuvent se situer entre 87
et 157 maintenant est-ce que le mode de
scrutin est ce que la situation locale
est-ce que les les consignes un peu
crapuleuses d'entre deux tours
d'appareils ne vont pas contrarier ce
scénario est ce qu'on regarde la
projection il faut enfin la projection
et fox et entre 20 et 45 sièges pour le
rassemblement on est loin des
scandales du mode de scrutin et si vous
voulez on a fait la dernière mandature
marine avait fait le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle on a fait la dernière
mandature avec six députés et et on
avait un sénateur c'est à dire que sur
1000 parlementaire on avait sept
parlementaires sur 1000 alors que nous
étions la première force politique ce
n'est pas une démocratie et je pense que
un pays qui veut fonctionner normalement
avec la crise de représentativité qu'on
a eus doit avoir une opposition qui est
conséquente et qui a les moyens d'agir
avec 25 députés nous n'avons pas les
moyens par exemple de déférer une loi ou
conseil constitue pas la preuve que la
dédiabolisation n'a pas marché le mode
de scrutin c'est le même pont jean luc
mélenchon et les sondages lui donnent
entre 80 et 100 députés pour la france
en sont alors jean-luc mélenchon alors
je vais vous expliquer parce que c'est
une question purement électorales c'est
que la gauche dispose de bastions
électoraux avec des villes imaginez que
marine est arrivé en tête dans au
premier tour de la présidentielle dans
vingt mille communes 20000 et pourtant
nous avons cette commune voyez le
décalage donc c'est cette implantation
locale qui fait qu' évidemment un dans
un scrutin majoritaire ces forces là
sont avantagés mais c'est de cet
artificielle parce qu'il ne représente
pas la réalité
électorale du pays quand madame hidalgo
fait moins de 2 % aux élections et
qu'elle va avoir beaucoup plus de
députés que le rassemblement national
s'il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas dans
ce pays alors c'est parce que disait son
âge uniquement sur le groupe psa on
verra on verra mais en tout cas en tout
cas il ya quelque chose qui est
totalement déséquilibré est totalement
anormale dans n'importe quel pays
d'europe nous serions pouvoir depuis 15
ans et là nous n'arrivons pas à avoir
quelques députés donc il faut corriger
cette injustice électorale en envoyant
le maximum de députés rn1 prochaine
assemblée
[Musique]